이거를 제가 여기서 썰을 풀려고 한 번도 얘기를 안 했었는데
헌트 라이킹 콩 투 위 주연에서 더 발전된 무기가 가미된 그런 일이 한 번 있었거든요
특수폭행 무기를 사용한 뭐냐면은
폼 롤리 롤리 롤리
안녕하세요 반갑습니다
안녕하세요
이거 사실 제가 일주일마다 공지를 해요 방송 공지를
악뮤 분들이 오신다고 하니까 난리가 났어요
감사합니다
오랜만이에요
몇 년만?
3년 만인 것 같습니다
그때 너무 반응이 좋았어요
그때 뭐 킹콩 펀치 같은 것도 좀 많이 배웠고
제가 그 이유를 좀 하려고 했는데 안 되더라고요
아 그게 어릴 때부터 해야 돼요? 유연할 때부터?
이후로 해야 되는데 이게 안 돼요
몸이 굳어있는 상태로는 못하고
원심력으로 해야 되는데
알겠습니다
자 그러면은 자기소개 한 번 부탁드리겠습니다
안녕하세요
여러분
오랜만입니다 악뮤 수현입니다
이천형입니다
오랜만에 방문하셨는데
제가 또 여쭤봤거든요
이번에도 따로 오셨냐 같이 오셨냐
너무 당연해서 따로 오고 왔습니다
같이 사시는데 따로 왔어요?
네
이유가?
몇 가지 있는데요
제일 중요한 거는 음악이 너무 달라요
그 출퇴근 음악
그러니까 수현이가 듣는 음악을 제가 같이 듣잖아요 한참 있으면
블루투스부터 쟁탈전이에요
거기부터 이미
아 오늘 하루 좋게 시작하고 싶은데
약간 안 맞는 거죠
첫 번째 경쟁은 앞자리 쟁탈전이고
왜냐면은 앞자리에 있으면 상대방이 안 보이잖아요
근데 뒷자리에 있으면 상대방이 보이잖아요
거기에서부터 심리적 어떤 우위를 일단 누가 점하냐
근데 보통 자기는 보이고 자기가 안 보이는 자리가 좋은 자리잖아요
아니에요 그냥 시야가
뒷좌석 사이로 삐져나온 머리카락이랑
살짝살짝 고개 돌릴 때마다 보이는 살짝 그 이목구비?
그니까 인지하고 싶지 않은데 인지를 해
그니까 이 사람하고 같은 공간에 있다는 거를 모르고 싶은데
보통 이제 핸드폰을 이렇게 하잖아요
뒷자리에서 하다가 아 목이 아프잖아요
어떻게 해?
아 근데 여기 보이죠?
거기서 이제 심리적으로 일단 오늘 하루를 진짜 잘 해야 되는데
아 거기서부터?
일단 그게 1번 그리고 두 번째는 음악이 수현이가 듣는 음악의 결이랑 제 음악의 결이랑 너무 달라요
어떻게 다른데요?
전 보통 J-POP만 들어가지고
애니메이션 OST 같은 거를 들으면서 텐션을 올리는 타입인데
예를 들면 무슨 곡이 있을까요?
뭐 예를 들면은 요즘에 뭐 체인소맨 엄청 이렇게 됐으니까
거기서 나오는 제인도우나 아니면은 뭐
그런 것들
근데 그게 싫어요?
아 싫다고
너무 별로야 그게?
아니 뭐 들어볼
말 잘해라
아니 사람들이 되게 좋아하는 노래인데 그냥 들을 수 있잖아요
근데 막 화가 날 정도로
음악가인데 음악가는 여러 음악을 다 섭취할 필요가 있을 텐데
이제 섭취라고 표현을 하셨으니까 음식을 계속 먹을 수가 없잖아요
저도 이제 끼니를 먹는 것처럼 딱 선정해서 아침 밥처럼 먹어야 되는데
이제 수현이가 먹고 싶은 거를 저한테 억지로
샌드위치만 계속 먹을 순 없으니까
그러니까요 또 수현이는 한식파라서 근데 전 양식파예요 그런 것도 다 달라요
그러면 찬영님은 뭘 들으세요?
수현이가 듣는 J-POP의 특징은 되게 이제 코드 변화가 많고
멜로디 변화가 이렇게 막 기승전결이 엄청나요
근데 저는 처음부터 끝까지 되게 전자 똑같은 거 같아요
루프 같은 거
아침부터 잠이 오는 거죠 이제 막 깼는데 오빠가 그 노래를 트는 순간 다시 잠이 드는 거죠
그럼 뭐 예를 들면 뭐예요 그런 노래가?
어 좀 클래시컬한 음악이나
쇼팽?
쇼팽까진 아니고요
몰리 드레이크라고 제가 제일 많이 듣는 앨범이 있어요 아침에
이름이 무슨 몬스터 같다 몰리 드레이크
아니에요?
아니죠 사람이죠
아니 뭐 메이플 같은데
개미굴에 있는 몰리 드레이크
아니면 뭐 주황즐베르토라고 베싸메무초
주황즐베르토? 이름이 주황이에요?
조왕
아 조왕
베싸메무초
아 그 노래 알아요?
네 유명한 노래
영화로도 있잖아요 베싸메
그 노래를 좋아하시는구나
그 앨범을 좋아합니다
아 그럼 스타일이 좀 다르네요
많이 달라요
확실히 좀 약간 수현님은 화려한 거 좋아하시나요 그러면?
네 저는 좀 약간 다이나믹한 노래들을 좋아하는 것 같아요
밴드 사운드 막 코드 변화
근데 수현님은 부르시는 노래는 되게 막 감성적이고
약간 그런 노래를 많이 하시지 않았어요?
그런 노래들은 이제 제가 가장 잘 부를 수 있는 노래들이고
또 듣는 취향은 다른 것 같아요
아 그렇구나
그러면은 아까 그렇게 표현을 하셨는데 졸리는 음악이라고 하셨는데
들으면은 그날 잠이 안 깨요?
그쵸 이제 저는 아침에 일단 일어나서 잠을 깨는 게 되게 느린 사람이에요
아 나도 그래
그쵸 그 한 번에 딱 뜨는 게 아니라 딱 뜨면 깰 때까지 좀 오래 걸리고
텐션을 그래도 좀 끌어올려서 일을 해야 되는데 차에 타면 어떤지
그거 왜 그런 줄 알아요?
운동 안 해서 그래
내가 그렇거든
내가 운동을 안 하니까 잠을 너무 늦게 깨더라고
신체가 빨리 안 들어와
주 5회 운동하고 있어요 근데
근데 요즘에 운동하니까 어때요?
빨리 깨지 않아요?
똑같다
아 똑같다
죄송합니다
나댔죠?
아무튼 그것 때문에 따로 오셨고
서로 양보할 생각은 없으시고
그리고 저희가 양보라는 게 참 어려운 게
저희가 뭐 1년 정도 같이 차를 쉐어한다 이러면은 뭔가 대책을 세울 수가 있겠는데
평생을 같이 한다고 생각하면 양보라는 개념이 이제 될 수가 없는 거죠
그리고 애초에 같이 간다는 생각을 이제
안 하는 거죠?
자연스럽게 따로 가는 거죠?
네네
그걸 생각해 본 지가 너무 오래됐네요
따로 같이 타면서
되게 스페셜할 때 우리 오늘 같이 탈까?
맞아
되게 스페셜
예를 들면 부모님 생신 그것도 아니에요?
1년에 한 번도 아니에요?
그것보다 더 스페셜해야 되긴 해요
더 스페셜해야 돼요
네 더 스페셜하고
근데 사실 이런 날이 스페셜한 날 아니야? 7년 만에 앨범 나오는 날
조금 더 스페셜해요
거의 다 왔는데 이거보다 조금 더 스페셜하면 좋을 것 같아요
거의 10년 단위로 가야 되네
네
거의
그 정도 되지 않을까
알겠습니다
자 그러면 23년도에 한 번 나와 주시고 이번에 또 나와 주셨는데
그동안 어떻게 쯤 지내셨는지가 좀 궁금하거든요
와 근데 벌써 3년이 됐다는 게 일단 믿기지가 않네요
체감은 어느 정도?
2년?
무려 1년이나 더
네
더 지난 거야
그래요?
세상에
1년이나
그렇게 차이나진 않네?
아니 꽤 나는 거지 사실은
사실 50%가 더 붙었으니까 주식으로 치면 50% 붙었다고 생각해보세요
저희가 같이 방송했었던 거를 제가 하도 돌려봐가지고
그걸 제가 3년 동안이나 돌려봤다고? 라는 생각이 드네요
본인 나온 것도 다시 보기도 해요?
제가 나온 거를 그렇게 자주 보진 않는데 침착맨 거는 보면서 계속 웃기더라고요
볼 때마다 웃기더라고요
계속 봤어요
사실은 오늘 어쨌든 스페셜한 날이잖아요
네
7년 만에 저희 4집이 나오는 스페셜한 자리에 스페셜한 시간에 이 발매일에 맞춰서 침착맨을 선택한 이유는 수현이랑 저랑 지금 같이 살고 있는데 거실에서 침착맨 방송이 끊이질 않아요
아
그쵸
그걸 볼 때 표정이 어때요? 되게 건조하게 이렇게
아니 계속 으흐흐? 으흐흐?
그것도 열받는 포인트겠네요 본인에게는
찬영님은 또 그런 걸로 쉽게 열받아 하잖아요
그렇죠
근데 저는 그래도 저렇게 행복해하면 방송이 정말 좋은 방송이라고 생각이 듭니다
그래서 이제 어쨌든 우리의 그 3년에 되게 좋은 영향을 준 수현이가 되게 좋은 영향을 준 방송이기 때문에 우리가 오늘 이 시간을 침착맨에서 보내야겠다
나름 의미가 있네
그러더라고요
사실은 3년 전에 오실 때 수현양은 좀 어느 정도 이 방송을 알고 오신 것 같은데요?
네
전 활동을 알고 오신 것 같은데 차장님은 아 제일 모른 채로 가자고 하니까 끌려온 거야
끌려왔는데 아이 그래 네가 그렇게 좋다면 내가 한번 맞춰줄게 느낌으로 왔단 말이에요
예
근데 그때보다는 조금은 같이 살면서 지나가면서 본 게 있으니까 조금은 이제 이해도가 있는 상태로 오신 거겠네요
저도 물 마시러 이제 거실에 왔다가 한 10분 동안 계속 보고 있는 거죠 할 일이 있는데 10분 보다가 어 이제 올라가야겠다
아
사실 굉장히 영상이 매니악해요 내용이
그런가요?
왜냐면 오래 보셔서 그래요
아 그런가요?
처음 본 사람은 거부감이 있기 마련이에요
지 맘대로 말하고 약간 막 폭력적이고
뭐 이런 것들
너무 저려졌나?
그럴 수 있어요
그래가지고 좀 나중에 그거를 보시는 분들은
평이 좀 안 좋더라고요
그래서 아마 찬용님도 그런 느낌이지 않을까
아 아니요 아니요
전 되게 호감입니다
무슨 소리야 깜짝이야
전 되게 호감이라고 생각합니다
근데 이제 두 분은 이제 그동안 3년간 뭐 하셨나 했더니
수현님은 요아소비 그때 얘기했었을 때
한 번 같이 해보고 싶다고 했는데
하셨어요 그 이후로
맞아요 그 사이에 요아소비 분들이
내한 오셨을 때 게스트로 나가가지고
저희가 같이 노래도 부르고
요아소비 노래도 부르고
저희 노래도 같이 부르고 그랬었죠
그러면 요아소비가
수현이..
수현님을 좀 같이 하고 싶어 가지고
연락을 해 가지고 같이 하게 된 거예요?
아니면 그냥 어떻게 어떻게
누가 먼저 하는지 모르겠지만
이렇게 얘기가 이렇게 딱 돼 가지고 간 거예요?
그런 식으로 됐어요
저희가 이제 언급하고 그랬던 것도 알고 계셨던 거 같고
그 후에 저희가 한 몇 번을 사실 만났었는데
그때 요아소비님들도 저희를 알고 있었다고
노래 좋아한다고 말씀해 주셔 가지고
서로 약간 너무 좋아요 팬이에요 이러면서
얘기도 하고 밥도 먹고 그랬었어요
걸림돌이 있다면
형님이 제이팝을 싫어한다는 건데
그걸 어떻게 스무스하게 넘어갔어요?
일단 일본어를 아예 못해서
약간 좀 스무스하게 넘어갈 수 있었죠
그렇게 말씀을 하시면 오해가 또 있으니까
아 그러면 제이팝을 다른 거보다 살짝 덜 좋아한다
라고 해야 될까?
좀 더 소프트하게?
좀 더 소프트한 게 뭐가 있지?
몰리 드레이크를 좋아한다
근데 요아소비는 리스펙이 있죠
아 리스펙이 있죠?
음악을 잘 하시고 노래도 잘 하시고
그리고 그때 우리가 봤을 때 되게 즐거웠어요
그 좀 밝은 기운이 있잖아요
저도 한 번 뵀었는데 주는 그 에너지가 있고
아 그리고 찬영님은 또 노래 그거 되게 중요시 하잖아요
가사
그래서 외국 곡 들을 때 가사 같은 거는 어떻게 음미를 하세요?
그래서 1차적으로 외국 곡을 들을 때
그게 걸림돌이 되는 것 같긴 해요
가사를 배제하고 이 질감으로만 판단을 해야 되니까
음 질감
네 거기서 많이 와닿지 않는 부분은 아니고요
그런 부분이 있는데
또 근데 뱃삼의 무초 같은 경우는
나중에 가사를 찾아보긴 했죠
근데 그거 배제하고도 질감이 너무
뱃삼의 무초는 무슨 내용이야?
잘 몰라요
모르겠는데 아무튼 그런 느낌 느낌
뭐 좋은 내용이었던 것 같아요
뱃삼의 무초라는 얘기가 영화로도 쓰일 정도면은
굉장히 대단한 내용이지 않겠어요?
저는 또 잘 몰라서요
그럼 세 명이 모였는데 뱃삼의 무초를 아는 사람이 한 분도 없네
뭐예요?
알려주세요
찾아본 적이 있는데 까먹었네요
아 맞을 거예요
근데 들으면서 다시 또 외국 노래니까
이 질감으로만 또 받아보니까
뱃삼의 무초는 그냥 뱃삼의 무초예요
개명사인 거죠
뱃삼의 무초요? 라고 하는데
하하하하하하하
내가 그거 언제 나오나 사실 속으로 카운트했거든요
근데 나오긴 나오는 거야
바로 나오는데요
자 그리고 이제 두 분은 또 그 사이에
소속사도 운영하시게 됐어요
네 독립을 했습니다
독립하신 이유가 있어요?
어 때가 됐다
배신할 때가 됐다
오우
어디미 근데
아하하하하하하
익숙해져야 해요 원래 이런 거
왜냐면은 약간 채널의 용어긴 해요
제가 이제 어디 딴 데로 가면
배신했다 그래요
악의가 없다
제가 그래서 배신맨이에요
왜냐면 플랫폼을 많이 옮겨 다녀가지고
지지직 갔다가 유튜브 갔다가
배신이라고 하면 좀 그렇고
졸업
계약 만료
근데 저희가 재계약을 한번 하긴 했었는데
엄청 많은 걸 배웠죠
배우는 와중에
이제 저의
프로듀싱의 범위가 너무 커지다 보니까
제 색깔이라는 게 되게 커지게 된 거예요
제가 원하는 게 너무 디테일해지고 하다 보니까
이제 회사의 색깔도 있고
제 색깔이 약간 분리되는 지점이 또 있는 거죠
근데 그걸 회사도 알고 저도 알고
그렇게 또 몇 년을 같이 활동을 하면서
서로 이제 알게 된 거죠
악뮤는 혼자서도 잘하겠다
근데 내가 느끼기에도 되게 중요한 부분들은
또 이렇게 배웠다
음
그래서 나와서도
우리가 원하는 것을 100% 구현할 수 있겠다
그리고 YG도 이제 응원한다
이런 아름다운 배신이라기보다는
아름다운 배신
정반대다 정반대
약간 그런 느낌일 것 같아
일을 같이 해요 YG에서 예를 들어
일을 하는데
이거 이렇게 해줬는데
아 이거는 이렇게 하는 게 좋겠어요
이제 피드백을 할 거 아니에요 분명히
이렇게 이런 거 디테일 하시니까
다 피드백을 해
하다 보니까 이만큼씩 넓어졌어 내가
그러니까 이 사람들이 사실은 할 게 없어
그러면 옆에서 가만히 있는 것도 고역이야
그러니까 나는
내가 어차피 범위가 너무 넓으니까
그냥 여기서 내꺼 하겠다
되는 거지
그렇게 자연스럽게 되지 않을까
사실 다 아시면서
정확하게 아시네요
왠지 그럴 것 같았어요
단어를 또 그렇게 사용을 하시네요
왠지 그럴 것 같아요
아시잖아요
저도 인터넷 방송이 저려져 가지고
배신이 주는 단어의 무게를 잘 몰랐어요
저는 이렇게 흔히 그냥 하는 말이라서
그런 뜻으로 한 건 아니고요
그냥 이별
이별을 말씀드린 거죠
수연양은 보통 이 프로젝트 할 때는 어떤 역할을 보통 하세요?
저는 사고 안 치기
1번 사고 안 치기
진짜 중요하죠
그럼 사고 안 쳤어요?
안 쳤죠
늘 안 쳤죠
그럼 자기를 다 한 거고
2번
웃어주기
웃어주기 그거 중요해요
많이 웃어주던가요?
지금 이렇게요
웃어주는 그 모먼트가 있는 거죠
웃기예요? 웃어주기예요?
웃어주기예요
정말 별로 안 웃긴데
아 별로 안 웃고 싶은데
한 번 선심쓰기
네
미소를 줌으로써
직원들을 행복하게 만들어줄 수 있고
뿌듯함을 느끼게 해줄 수 있잖아요
그래서 한 번씩
저는 매일 아침에 운동을 해요
코치님이랑
그럼 러닝을 해서
회사에 가끔씩 가요
가서 등장해서
화나게 웃어주고
가요
다시
그게 이제 웃어주기
그러면 하시는 업무를 정리해보면
1번 사고 안 치기
2번 웃어주기
그러면 공 만드는 거나 운영에 있어서
더 직접적으로 관여하는 일은 없어요?
그런 일은 없는 거 같아요
그런 일은 없고
애니메이션 추천하기?
애니메이션 추천하기도 가끔 있는 일이고
저희 정규 회의 때 한 번씩 애니메이션 추천해주고
애니메이션 그러면 좀 추천받은 건 좀 보세요
옛날에 한 번 봤어요
왜냐면 우리가 같이 살게 되면서
초창기에 같이 살게 된 초창기에
어쨌든 같이 사니까
서로의 취향을 좀 공유를 해보자 하고
진격의 거인 그거 봤어요
근데 막 뒤쪽에 재밌어진대요
네
네?
제이...
제이팝은 뭐
몰리 드레이크보다는 선호하지 않는데
제이 애니메이션을 추천을 받았어요
제이 애니
뒤쪽으로 갈수록 재밌어진대요
그래서 제가 이제 중후반부까지는 좀 참고 봤어요
그랬어?
참았구나
어디까지야 그러면 그게?
그래도 막 거인이 좀 많이 나왔어
그 뭐야 그 설산
설산 거인까지 나왔어
설산 거인 뭐야 도대체?
원숭이 거인
예예
숭이 거인
숭이 거인까지 나왔구나
그럼 사실 그때가 제일 재밌는데
참았다는 거 자체가 이미 안 맞는 거라고 봐야 돼요
그러니까 왜냐하면
자기 얘기를 이제 계속 하잖아요
그 L&E
정리된 이 결론이 아니고
그 결론까지 가기 위한
자기의 생각의 흐름들을 다 해주잖아요
근데 저는 제가 생각이 너무 많아요
근데 저 사람이 나한테
너무 많은 생각거리를 이렇게 주는 게
좀 부담스럽더라고요
내가 생각하고 싶은데
자꾸 생각할 시간에 생각하니까
생각을 또 말로 하잖아요
그러니까 자꾸 내 생각하고 겹쳐가지고
보면서 생각 정리가 안 되고
피로하고
맞아요
근데 이렇게 막 하나하나 설명하고
이런 게 너무 싫다는 거예요
설명조를 싫어하시는 거 같아요
네 맞아요
자연스럽게 풀어나가는
내가 생각하고 싶은데
이 캐릭터가 생각하는 방향을
내가 따라가야 되잖아요
그리고 그게 막 한 5분 동안 얘기를 해요
얼굴만 계속 측면 정면
이렇게 보여주면서
막 한참 동안 들었어요
근데 아닌가?
로 끝내
그러면
아 그럼 열이 확 받는 거예요
아 그치 열 받을 수
나 그런 관점 사실 생각 못 해봤는데
아 그럴 수 있겠다
그냥 근데 그럴듯 하거든요 추측이
그래가지고 어 아닌가 하면 완전
우린 반전이라고 받아들인데
보통 열 받는다고 표현하시는구나
되게 집중해서
그래 뭘 말하는지 좀 들어보자
라고 했는데
정말 그냥 생각의 흐름을
그냥 나열해 놓은 거였던 거죠
그럼 우리들은 반전이라고 하잖아요
그쵸
그리고 그 설명이 다 하나하나
복선이 있고
의미가 있고
뜻이 있고
이거 다 이제 들어야 되는
그 과정들인데
그래서 오빠는 왜 그냥 보여주면 되지
말로 저렇게 다 하냐
이렇게 말을 해요
근데 오빠가 유일하게 좋아하는 게
애니메이션이 원피스예요
그거 설명 덕지덕지
그래서 제가 저렇게 까다로운 기준으로
애니메이션을 안 보니까
그래 얼마나 명작인지 한번 보자
그래서 전 어릴 때 원피스를 안 봤어가지고
나중에 이제 원피스를 딱 봤는데
웬 그냥 스피드웨건들밖에 없는 거야
하하하하하
다 변사야 다 변사
가만히 서가지고 설명밖에 안 해
두 가지 이유가 있는데요
원피스는 어릴 적에 저의 마음을 오르만져준
어렸을 때 이미 내가 가스라이팅이 돼버렸어요
맞아요 이미
이미 나는 얘한테 호감이야
네 이미 저도 그 후반부로 갈수록 좀 지루하고
그런 부분들이 있었죠
근데 의리가 이미 생겨버린 거죠
그래 원피스는 다 의리로 보더라고요
그게 어렸을 때 뭘 보느냐가 되게 중요해요
그 시기 때 안 보면
시기를 놓치면 못 보는 만화들이 있거든요
근데 원피스를 어렸을 때 보셔가지고
아마 그런 게 있는 것 같고
최근 어디까지 보셨어요 그러면
빅맘이랑 그까지 두 명 다 잠든 것까지 기억이 나요
아 거의 최근이네 안 보셔서
아무튼 다시 돌아가서
소속사를 자기만의 소속사를 세우셨는데
이름이 영감의 샘터예요
근데 이거 이제 질문들이 좀 많잖아요
왜 영감의 샘터냐
보통 뭐라고 대답을 하시나요
그냥 제가 데뷔 때부터 사람들이 제일 많이
저한테 하는 질문 두 개가 있었는데
하나는 수현이 어디 있냐
하나는 영감을 어디서 봤냐
근데 거기에 제가 이제 데뷔 초에 나름 대답을 했어요
아 영감은 뭐 어떻게 어떻게
근데 지금 방송 나온 지는 13년 됐단 말이에요
지금까지도 영감은 어디서 받아요 이렇게 한단 말이에요
그치 궁금하거든
아직까지
궁금해
어디서 계속 나오는지 궁금하잖아
궁금할 수 있어
근데 이게 어떻게 말하냐
이게 더 중요한 것 같아요
이게 영감이 어디서 나오느냐가 사실 중요한 게 아니고
되게 흔하거든
맞아요 맞아요
그래서 말을 어떻게 임팩트 있게 말하냐
그래서 아 우리 회사에 우물이 있다
영감의 샘터가 있다
거기서 하나씩 떠 맞은다
미친 대답이다 진짜
그러면 이제 되게 신비인 것 같아요
신비한 공간처럼 되잖아요
실제로 그렇게 하고 있고요
샘물을 마십니다
실제로 그 안에 샘물이 있어요
그래서 떠 마시면 조금 도움이 돼요
도움 정도가 아니에요
그럼 사실상 곡은 그 샘물이 썼다고 봐야겠네요
그렇겠네요 그렇게 치면 도움 정도가 아니라고 하면
그럼 공동 저작자로
샘물이 근데 자아가 있지는 않기 때문에
AI 같은 거죠
근데 이제 그 직원분들을 영감이라고
소개를 해주시는 건데
무슨 이유예요
영감은 어차피 샘물에서 얻는데
그분들한테서도 얻어요
약간 이중
이중으로
그러면 그냥 돌아다니는 아이템 덩어리라고
이제 인지를 하시는 거예요
인간으로 보지 않고
돌아다니는 어떤 자극 요소들
이런 것도 있어요
저희가 이제 회사를 만들었다고 하지만
회사라는 단어가 제일 이해하기 쉽기 때문에 그렇게 했어요
근데 결국에는 회사가 중요한 게 아니고
제일 중요한 거구나
내가 누구랑 일을 하냐
그리고 누구랑 무슨 경험을 하냐가 제일 중요한 거구나
그래서 이분들이랑 내가 어디 봉사활동을 가든
아니면 여행을 가든
다 덩어리로 이렇게 움직여요
그러면서 나중에 내가 이런 곡을 이제 쓰고 내려고 하는데
이 경험들을 같이 안 했으면 다 설명해야 되는 거죠
내가 이번에 어디 가서 무슨 경험을 했는데
근데 이제 영감들이니까
그냥 나 이번에 이런 곡 썼는데 하면
바로 알지
나도 이거 뭔지 알아요
일이 빠르게 되겠네
그렇죠
그러면 수연 님도 영감 중에 하나예요?
아니요 저는 공주
영감이라고 부르지 않고 공주라고 불러요?
공주라고 불리우고 있어요
비공식적으로
왜냐면 영감을 안 줘서?
저는 약간 영감의 원천 쪽에 가깝고
그래서 영감님이라기보다는 공주로서
이렇게 공주들이 백성들을 돌보고 하잖아요
저는 영감님들을 좀 돌보고
그러면 영감이라는 어감이 싫어서 아니에요?
너무 노인 같아가지고
아니요 그런 건 아닌데
그냥 당연히?
당연스러운 거?
그럼 이제 영감들을 다 케어해주는 사람?
케어하기보다는 미소 주기, 웃어주기
사실 이게 되게 대단한 게 뭐냐면
부모를 높이는 거거든
부모가 왕이어야지 본인이 이제 공주가 되잖아요
부모님을 높이는 것도 있대요
옛날에 이성계가 왕이 되고
부모님들 다 왕 됐잖아요
그런 느낌으로 좀 생각을 하시는 건가요?
그렇게 생각해 본 적은 없는데
일리가 있네요
그러면 이제 동시에 왕자가 되나요?
왕자가 되는 거잖아요 공주가 되면
그거는 좀 다른 거 같고
뭐라고 불러요?
여기는 샘터장
아 우물 관리하시는?
뭐 책임자? 총책임자?
장
장?
장이죠
그러면 실제로 그렇게 왔다 갔다 해요?
영감님 이거 해주세요
장님 이거 해주세요 공주님 이렇게
샘터장님 하고 저한테는 공주님
신기하다
그분들은 막 우리 충분히 젊은데
영감이라고 하는 거는
아니 지금 되게 나네요?
너무 좋아요
좋아하는 사람들만 모아놨어요
그게 또 입자 조건이에요
그거를
첫 번째 관문이구나
영감이라고 부르는 거에 거부감이 없을 것이
그래서 뭐 이 영감, 김 영감, 황 영감, 고 영감
이렇게 다 있는데
그래서 저희 직원들 조건이
성이 다 달라야 돼요
아 겹치니까
겹치면 안 되니까
지금은 실제로 다 다르시거든요
아니 풀네임하고 영감 붙여도 되는데
그거는 안 돼
고 영감 뭐 이렇게 해야 되니까
영감분들 그걸 좋아하시고
너무 좋아하시고
그리고 이제 두 분 이제 같이 사신 지가 좀 한 1년 넘으셨죠?
1년 넘었어요
넘었죠
같이 사시면서 맞는 거 안 맞는 거 뭐 이런 거 있을 거 같은데
의외로 맞는 건 이런 거 있었다 뭐 이런 거 있어요?
다 안 맞을 줄 알았는데
어 이런 거는 그래도 의외로 괜찮더라
없나?
몽골에서는 어떻게 살았어?
이렇게 안 맞는데
먼저 말해봐
맞는 거?
맞는 거
그러면 1분 드릴게요
1분? 1분밖에 안 주신다고요?
회사 갔다 오실래요?
생물이라도 좀 퍼드시게
맞다라는 게
그게 뭐지?
그치
맞다라는 게 뭐였죠?
이쪽이 좋아하는 게 이쪽이 좋아하는
어? 우리가 사실은 좋아하는 게 겹치는 게 있네
집
어 그치 집을 공유하고 있죠
그게 개념이 내가 좋아하는 거
그 집이 좋아요?
네
얘도 좋아요
아 좋아요?
집을 좋아해요
그 집이 좋아요?
네
그 집을 좋아해요
아 그러면 그게 겹치는구나
그래서 사는 건가?
졸라 어렵네
그럼 시작이 나는 그렇게 알고 있었거든요
혼자 있는 게 조금 불안해 보여서 같이 살자고 한 줄 알았는데
그 집이 좋아서 같이 산 거였어?
저를 꼬신 게 그 집이었어요
저를 이제 고양이한테 이렇게 깃털을 흔들어 주듯이
제 시선을 뺏은 게 그 집이었어요
아
저한테 정확히 그 집을 보여주면서
여기 되게 예쁘지 않아?
와 너 근데 이런 데 살고 싶다고 하지 않았나?
공간 분리도 잘 돼 있고
공간 분리가 정말 잘 돼 있어
근데 나도 여기 들어가고 싶은데 조금 월세가 부담스럽다
괜찮으면 반반해서 같이 들어가 볼래?
쉐어하우스 해 볼래?
이런 식으로 저를 이제
유도를 했어요
안에는 시커먼 어떤 속내를 가지고
새하얀
아 새하얀
새하얀 속내를 숨기고?
속내를 숨기고?
야 한 번만 걸려봐
그리고 우리는 진짜 서로 좋아하는 이 집에 같이 살 수 있어
이 새하얀 속내를 절대 들키지 말아야지
네 그러면서 되게 아무렇지 않은 것처럼
한번 쉐어하우스 해 볼래?
비용도 절약되고
뭐 같이 있으면서 앨범도 같이 만들고
분명히 제가 기억하는 게 들어가면
거기 테라스가 있으니까
날씨 좋을 때 그림도 같이 그리고
책도 읽고
유유자족함
라이프?
너무 좋은데?
이러고 들어갔는데
들어가자마자 디톡스를 시키더라고
3일 동안
디톡스라는 거는 이제 전자제품 같은 거를
아뇨 아뇨 진짜로
못 먹게 하더라고요
아 먹는 거를?
먹는 거를 이제 싹 하고
무슨 케일 주스랑 비트 주스만 3일 동안 먹이고
다시 태어나라고
해병대처럼?
너의 몸만
그거는 해병대에서 배운 거야?
그런 커리큘럼은?
뭐 그렇다고 볼 수 있어요
그럼 어떻게 보면 해병대에 들어가신 거는
수연양을 좀 변화시키기 위해서
내가 먼저 이 커리큘럼을 배워오겠다는 느낌으로
가신 걸 수도 있겠네요
또 지금 생각해보면
운명적으로
운명적이라고 생각이 들어요
일회성인 건 없다 인생에서
이게 다 어떻게 다 끼워 맞춰지게 돼있다
영향을 계속 다 줄 수밖에 없고
아 그러면은 가자마자 속았다
에이 진짜 정확히 그거였어요
디톡스를 하는 3일 내내
뭔가 잘못됐다
내가 또 당했구나
와 큰일 났다
아니야 디톡스만 하고
그냥 온 기념으로 하는 거다
입주 기념식처럼
온 기념으로 해병대식 디톡스를 했는데
이거는 뭐 3일이면 끝이 나요
파티
파티 파티 디톡스 파티
디톡스 파티
케일 주스 파티
그런가보다 또 이렇게 있었는데
갑자기 우리 이제 운동을 좀 같이 하면 좋을 것 같아서
코치님을 한번 알아보자
이렇게 해가지고
그래 운동은 좀 그래도 해야지
건강을 위해서 이렇게 했는데
제가 헬스장을 나가는 시스템이면
제가 못 나가니까
맨날 아프다 못 일어나겠다
그렇게 했죠
이렇게 하니까
코치님을 집으로 11시만 되면은
초인종을 누르게끔 시스템을 만들어 놓고
아프든 말든 그냥 내려와야 되는 거예요
주 처음에 2회 얘기했었는데
지금 주 5회 하고 있고요
그러면은 새하얀 손해를 그때 몰랐어요?
전혀 몰랐어요
그 케일 주스 파티가 끝나고
진짜 그림 그리면서 유유자적하게 보낼 수 있겠구나 했는데
그래서 물감도 샀는데
단 한 번도 뜯어보질 못했어요
제 입장에서는 너무 자연스러운 거 같아요
당연히 새 집에 들어가면 파티를 해야 되잖아요
파티
근데 파티를 왜 케일 주스 파티로?
뭐 기왕 하는 거 좀 좋은 걸로
좋은 걸로 몸에 좋은 걸로
제일 좋은 걸로
안 좋은 걸로 하는 게 어떻게 파티예요
좋은 걸로 하는 게 파티지
파티 다음에 당연히 따라오는 거 뭐가 있겠어
당연히 따라오는 거?
PT
PT가 왜 따라와요?
파티
합질 뒤에 PT예요?
아 파티 다음 PT였어?
그게 자연스럽다?
그렇죠
어감으로 보나 뭘로 보나 되게 자연스럽다
파티 PT
그 다음 따라오는 게 뭐예요?
PT
아 이게 세 단계로 계획이 있었구나
파티 PT, 뷰티
그리고 실제로 이 뷰티가
채팅창에 계속
계속 사실 제가 읽진 않았지만
너무 예쁘다라는 게
지금 3단계를 접어둔 거예요?
4단계도 있어요?
4단계?
궁금하다
저희 항상 미리 말해주지 않거든요
그럼 좀 숨겨야 되나?
파티 PT, 뷰티?
이제 베팅이에요
이제 여기 뷰티까지는 제가 만들어줄 수 있어요?
근데 그 다음은 자기가 해야 돼요
내가 베팅을 할 수 없어요
생긴 이 밑천으로 걸어야 돼?
네
그게 이제 본인의 영역이네
그게 다음 단계인데요
이제 저희가 2년 합숙을 계획을 했어요
그리고 벌써 1년 하고 4, 5개월 지난 것 같아요
남은 기간 동안 좀 훈련을 해야 되는 부분이 베팅입니다
그러면 두 분이 이제 공감대가 사실 그 집이 좋다라는 건데
2년 뒤에 그러면 헤어지는 거예요?
내년에 헤어집니다
집이 좋은데 이제 더 이상
2년 계약을 했어요
추가로 계약할 수도 있잖아 시도를
그걸 감수할 만큼 또 좋은 것 같진 않고
그런 건 있어요
이 이후 2년은 우리가 멀리 살진 말자
코치님은 우리가 약속해놓은 게 있고 프로그램은 또 따르고
그 2단계는 왜 안 끝나요?
PT요?
PT?
이게 물려서 가는 거예요
끝나는 게 아니에요
그 위에 단계로 가서 다 파티 PT 뷰티를 받는 거예요
파티도 지금 계속 하고 있는 거예요?
네
한 3개월 단위로 하고 있습니다
무슨 파티가?
디톡스 파티
아 K-Juice 파티를?
실제로 한 달 전에 또 했었어요
K-Juice 파티를?
네 K-Juice 파티
아 그게 단계로 넘어갔다고 해서 전 단계를 안 하는 게 아니고
그것도 하면서 포함해서 하는 거구나
그런 거 같고 패시브처럼
근데 수연 님은 언제든지 탈출할 수 있는 틈이 있었을 거 아니에요
근데 안 한 이유는 뭔가 이게 싫지만 좋다 가 있었을 것 같은데
싫지만 선택의 여지가 없다
저에게 들이미는 것을 먹으면 어떻게 될지
그리고 안 먹으면 어떻게 될지 보이잖아요
오빠가 건네주는 이 파티를 하면
일주일 후에 어떤 사람이 되어 있을지
이걸 안 하면 어떻게 돼 있을지 알잖아요
욕망을 이용했구나 악마처럼
그 뭐 파우스트나 뭐 이런 데 나오는 악마
천사처럼
천사처럼 욕망을 이용했구나
새하얀 마음을
새하얀 마음을 숨기고 천사처럼 속였구나
그렇죠
욕망을 이용해서
이걸 안 하면은 저는 지금이랑 똑같은 사람이 돼 있을 거고
일주일 후에 이걸 하면 조금 다른 사람이 되어 있지 않을까
이거를 제가 머릿속으로 알고 있으니까
너무 싫고 진짜 때리고 싶지만
오케이 2번만 하면서 하는 거죠
천사의 유혹을 못 이기고
그쵸
천류를 못 이기고 계속 그냥 2번만 2번만 2번만 하면서
거의 1년 넘게 이렇게 살다 보니
그게 1년 4개월이야
네 1년 4개월을 살다 보니까 이렇게 됐습니다
알겠습니다
그러면 수연 님은?
수연 님은 원래 이제 운동하기 전에
각자 따로 사셨을 거 아니에요
그때는 뭐 좀 게임 같은 걸 많이 하셨어요?
아 지금도 많이 하고 있고요
아 지금도?
근데 지금은 게임도 하는 거죠
이제 많은 것들을 하면서 게임도 하는데
그 당시엔 게임만 했었고
보통 무슨 게임 하셨어요?
저는 여러 가지 게임을 하는데
뭐 하나에 빠져서 했던 거는 뭐 한 두 개 정도 밖에 없고
나머지는 이제 스팀에 있는 여러 인디 게임들을
새로 나오면 하시고?
네네 그런 타입인데
몇백 시간씩 했던 거는 젤다의 전설
아
열심히 하셨던 거
젤다의 전설
저 할 때 되게 잘하던가요?
보면서 어때요?
그 신수들 물리칠 때
이렇게 해도 깨네 하면서
잘하신다 이런 생각을 한 적 있어요 혹시?
질문 자체가 되게 일방적이어가지고 지금
아니 그냥 원하는 생각하신대로
막 활도 막 번개 화살 20개 모아서 쏘고
아 이게 지금 악뮤에 수연 위로 얘기를 해야 될지?
지금 순위로 얘기를 해야 될지?
잘 모르겠기는 한데
편하게 얘기하세요
잘했으면 잘했다고 하는 것도 용기에요
용기?
왜냐면 사람들은 못했다고 가스라이팅을 하거든요
제가 게임을 나쁘지 않게 해요
근데 자꾸 못했다고 하니까
그것 때문에 눈치 보이시는 거 같아요
왜냐면 아무래도 대중들의 관심을 받고
또 이런 활동을 하는 음악가들이니까
이게 습관화 돼있어
이게 남이 싫어하는 말은 쉽게 뱉지 못하는 거 같아.
그래서 나는 그거에서 용기를 내는 것도 나쁘지 않은데
솔직하게
어 뭐 근데 제가 이제 조금 오 하고 놀랐던 건
전투를 생각보다 잘하셨대요
잘한다
전투를 생각보다 잘하셨나
퍼즐도
제가 그 4단 깨시는 것들을 보면서
제가 정확히 기억이 나는데
밥 먹고 있었거든요
밥을 차리면서 이제 그걸 생방으로 보고 있었어요
4단에 딱 들어가시길래
어 그렇구나 저거 제가 다 해봤던 거니까
아 저거는 저렇게 해서 그냥 딱 깨면 되는 거
어구나 저기 들어가셨네 하고 밥을 먹었는데
밥을 다 먹고 설거지를 하고 있는데 아직도
거기에 계신 것을 보고 한숨을 한 번 후
지금 꺼드럭대신 거예요?
조금
그거는 보셨어요 제 짤?
그 젤다의 전설 굴러가지고 죽은 거
굴러가지고 죽은 거
못 보셨구나
어디서 굴러셨어요?
그 비탈에서 굴렀는데 계속 굴러서 죽은 거 있었어요
아 그쵸
알겠습니다
그러면 이제 뭐 애니메이션은 진격의 거인?
너무 많은데 다 이야기할 수는 없고
이제 진격 거 보셨던 거
그것도 생방으로 봤었고
그리고 편집본 나왔을 때 편집본도 보고
원본 박물관으로도 보고
제가 좋아하는 어떤 콘텐츠가
또 제가 좋아하는 사람이 이걸 같이 결합이 되니까
진짜 너무 행복했어요
재밌어요 그러면?
너무 재밌어요
사실 제가 관심 없는 거를 하셔도 저는 재밌거든요
근데 제가 너무 사랑하는 콘텐츠를 다루시니까
그거는 진짜 계속 봐요 계속
젤다의 전설
젤다의 전설이랑 진격 거랑 GTA랑
이거는 제가 그냥 심심하면 계속 봐요
근데 이제 그렇게 게임 좋아하시고 이렇게 했는데
이제는 게임도 하시지만 운동도 하시고
여러 가지 하는 게 다양화됐어요
그쵸
그러면 이제 같이 사시면서
찬영님이 조금 그런 걸 유도하셨을 텐데
그렇죠 프로그래밍을 다 했죠
일단 들어가자마자 제일 먼저 한 게 시간표 짠 거였어요
우리가 디톡스 할 때
아 여기 붙였잖아요 그때
그거는 또 특수한 합숙? 뭐라 그러냐?
합숙 안에 합숙
아 합숙 오브 합숙
합숙 오브 합숙
합숙 하는 와중에 우리가 전지훈련을 또 가서
하드 트레이닝을 한 기간이 있어요
그거는 그거용 시간표였고
저희 어렸을 때 홈스쿨링할 때 그렇게 했었거든요
시간표를 짜는 거
우리 어렸을 때 추억 살리면서 한번 시켰어요
항상 이런 식이에요
사실은 되게 빡센 어떤 프로그램인데
그거 하나하나를 설명할 때 되게 아무렇지 않은 듯이
마치 게임이라도 하는 것처럼
우리 재밌는 시간표 짜기 한번 해볼까? 약간 이런 식이에요
그게 악덕 상인들이 보통 하는 행동들인데
중요한 거는
중요한 건 하얀 마음
새하얀 마음
새하얀 마음을 갖고 흘리듯이 말해서
응 하면 네가 좋다고 했잖아
하고 디테일을 나중에 푸는 거야
그러면 내가 말했으니까 여기서 가스라이팅을 당해요
내가 오케이 해가지고 할 말이 없네?
사실 할 말이 있는 거거든요
디테일한 거 못 들었어
근데 분위기에 휩쓸려서
내가 맞다고 했으니까 뭐 별 수 없지 뭐 이렇게 돼버려요
그리고 항상 뭔가
싸울 때 침착한 사람이 이기는 거 아시죠?
맞아요
근데 항상 그런 느낌이에요
그래서 제가 나 이거 또 속았는데?
너무 억울한데?
어머 화가 나요
근데 아유 뭐
항상 너무 당당하니까
나한테 이런 말 없었잖아
이렇게까지 힘들 거라고 얘기 안 했잖아
근데 하는 김에
하는 김에 이렇게 하는 거지
지금 약간 대화가 저를 나쁜 사람으로 만든 거 같은데
아니요 천사처럼 말하는 거야
사람 한 명 살린 거예요 제가
아 사람 한 명
보통 자기 입으로 그런 말을 안 하는데
여기는 잘해요 잘해요
새하얀 마음을 더 이상 못 숨겼어 이제
그러면은 막 구타도 계속 버렸어
킹콩 펀치도 계속 했어요 그러면?
운동을 시키면서 잘 안 하면 구타도 동반했어요?
참지 못하는 순간이 있었죠
아 이거를 제가 여기서 썰을 풀려고 한 번도 얘기를 안 했었는데
여기서 말하려고 여기서 말하려고 썰을 한 번도 안 풀었대
저희가 진짜..
얼마 전에 레전드 사건이 한 번 있었어요
펀칠라이 킹콩 트위 주연에서 더 발전된
무기가 가미된 그런 일이 한 번 있었거든요
특수폭행 무기를 사용한
뭐냐면은 그 스킬명
스킬명?
롤린롤린롤린
롤린롤린롤린 그거는 락 가사잖아요 그쵸?
근데 앞에 하나 더 붙어요 폼 롤린롤린롤린
폼 롤린롤린
이건 스킬명이고 그 대전이 폼롤러 대전이라고 이야기하고 있고
폼롤러 사건이라고도 이야기하고 있는데
이게 이 전제가 있었는데
그날이 제가 운동을 두 번 하는 날이었어요
근데 그 전날에 제가 몸무게를 1키로를 빼오면은
그 다음날에 PT 두 개를
되게 저강도로 해주시겠다
라고 코치님이랑 약속을 한 상태였어요
보상이 있어요?
근데 그 전날에 제가 그걸 성공을 한 거예요
그래서 나는 오늘 2회 저강도로 하기로 했어요
첫 번째 PT가 러닝이었는데
저강도가 아니었어요 중강도였어요
그래서 지금 좀 화가 나 있는 상태였었죠
아 나 이거 밥 먹고 두 번째 PT를 할 텐데
이때 제 저강도 아니면
저 나가겠다 저 지금 나갈 거다
안 할 거예요 이러면서
두 번째 PT를 시작했는데
오빠는 아무것도 모르는 상태에서
두 번째 PT 때 같이 운동을 하기로 했어요
그래서 저강도를 하기로 한 거예요
들어왔는데
자 차장님 차장님 오늘 할 운동은 이런 거입니다
하면서 따다다닥 브리핑을 하는데
저강도가 아닌 거예요
네
그래서 제가
화가 너무 나지
바로 이제 책상 업고
나 안 해!
이렇게 한 거예요
나 안 해
열받지
왜 이 사람들을 약속을 안 지키는 거야
이러면서 제가 막 땡깡을 불기 시작했죠
바닥에 누워가지고
나 안 해 이렇게 약속을 안 지키는 사람들은
나 아무것도 못 해
막 이렇게 하고 있었는데
오빠가 그 장면을 보고
갑자기 화가 너무 났던 거죠
나 화가 안 났어
그래?
그럼 왜
그때 감정이 뭐였어
멀었구나
기본적으로 깔아보네
기본적으로 깔아봐
동등한 게 아니에요 그냥
되게 깔아봐
한 단계 내리는 게 아니고
각도가 한 4단계가 아래 있어
멀었다
아니 근데 이제
바닥에서 으
근데 가르치고
사람 되려면 멀었구나잖아 이게
근데 이게
둘만 있는 것도 아니고
코치님이 우리를 위해서 집까지 와주시잖아요
근데 이게
근데 이제
그래
rill
쉬엉
펄
넘어간 대결
ISIS
enee
이제 약간 싸울 것 같으니까 무서웠는지 입을 꼭 담으시더라구요
선생님의 욕심 때문에 그걸 안해준거였어 사실은
근데 오빠는 몰랐고
오빠는 모르는 상태였고 저는 억울한 상태였고
그래서 이제 땡깡을 이어가다가
갑자기 이제 오빠가 너 내가 하게 할 수 있어 이러는거에요
그래서 제가 거기서도 조금 이제 저도 이제 긁힌거죠
그래서 아니 나는 오빠가 하게 한다고 해도 나는 안 할 수 있어
아니 넌 하게 될 거야 아니 난 안 할 거야
이렇게 되면서 약간 이게 진짜 감정이 올라왔어
화가 살짝 둘 다 난거죠
여기서 이제 코치님은 오 마이 갓 이렇게 된거고
그러더니 갑자기 오빠가 코치님 잠시만 진지한 대화를 좀 하겠습니다
갑자기 내보내고 방문을 잠갔어요
저는 아직 누워있는 상태잖아요 무방비 상태였어요
근데 그 상태에서 갑자기 핑크색 폼롤러를 들었어요
폼
폼롤러
아 그거를 서로 감정이 올라왔을 때
감정이 올라왔는데 폼 롤링 롤링 스킬을 시전을 한거죠
저는 동등하게 같이 폼롤러를 가지고 싸울 수 있었다면
어떻게든 뭔가를 해봤을 수 있겠지만
일방적으로 본인이 먼저 시작을 해버린 거죠
저는 누워있는데
그래서 그 상태로 무자비하게 당하다가
아 미안해 이렇게 소리를 질렀더니 바로 멈추더라고요
브레이크가 그래도 잡혔어요
그래서 그 상태로 나 진짜 미안해 다 할게
이렇게 하고
방문이 열리자마자 바로 제 방으로 달려가가지고 문을 잠갔죠
아 거짓으로
시커먼 속마음을 숨기고 나는 사실 할 생각 없었는데
바로 도망가가지고 방문 잠가가지고 있었죠
오빠가 뒤에서
또 이렇게 해서 나와
누가 나와 그렇게 하면
그니까요 무섭잖아요 그래서
난 방금까지 스킬을 당했는데 피해자인데 그래서
싫다 또 폼롤러 갖고 왔냐 했더니 안 갖고 왔대
안 갖고 왔으니까 열을 해요 그래가지고 열고
우리가 지금 상황이 이렇게 됐지만 그래도 운동은 해야 되겠다
이렇게 말씀을 하셔서 다시 내려가서 셋이서 스트레칭을 하다가
갑자기 너무 억울한 거예요 눈물이 갑자기 미친듯이 나는 거예요
다시 올라가가지고 문을 잠그고 집을 알아봤어요
나갈 집?
네
그건 아셨어요?
집 알아봤는데 몰랐어요
바로 이 근처에 최대한 빨리 나갈 수 있는 집이 어디 있을까
나는 이렇게는 못 살겠다
서로 공통되게 좋아했던 게 유일한 게 그 집인데
그것마저 싫어졌어
싫어진 거죠 이 공간도시고 모든 게 다시
폼 롤러 롤러 롤러 때문에
폼 롤링 롤링 롤링
왜 이렇게 정확하게 알아요
당했으니까 알죠 당했으니까 알고
그래서 그걸 알아보다가
아 그래도 진짜 나가는 건 아닌 거 같아서
다시 문을 열고 코치님을 보내고
둘이 이제 이야기를 하면서 좀 이제 풀었던 사과를 받고
다시는 그렇게 안 하겠다 너도 그러지 말아라
나는 억울한 상황이 있었다 서로 이야기하면서
그걸 엄밀히 말하면 코치님이 제대로 안 하신 거야
저는 좀 그렇게 생각해요
근데 이게 정해졌었어요
저강도 중강도가 이게 기준이 있어요
그게 문제예요 그게 안 정해져 있었어요
그러니까 코치님은 줄여졌다고 생각하고 줄인 거고
여기는 별로 생각보다 안 줄여졌다고 해서
그게 의견이 이게 안 맞았구나
저한테 저강도가 아니었는데
코치님한테는 저강도였을 수도 있겠죠
코치님 나름 봐준 건데
네 그런 거죠
그래서 그때 코치님이랑도 얘기해서
우리 이런 사건이 있었으니 앞으로는 더 명확히
이야기를 하도록 하자
그 찬영님은 같이 설정한 게 해병 한 명 만들려고 한 거 아니에요?
아냐 아냐
지금 해병이 거의 돼가고 있어요
지금 명예해병이야
명예해병
말이 하려면 길어요?
너무 많은 일이 있었어요
우리 합숙하는 동안에 너무 많은 일이 있었어요
근데 별개로 머리카락이 왜 이렇게 길어요?
아 이거는 붙인 거예요
제 머리카락은 이 정도 해요
이것도 엄청 긴데 이만큼을 붙이신 이유가 있어요?
그 앨범의 컨셉이랑 맞아요?
이거를 오빠가 한 1년 전부터 얘기를 했었거든요
너는 개화 때 이 머리를 해야 된다 하면서
저한테 보여준 사진이 해그리드 사진이었어요
저 해리포터의 해그리드 사진을 보여주면서
해그리드 그건 맞아요 길이는?
길이는 맞죠
그래서 제가 어?
헤르미온느 있는데 왜 굳이 해그리드냐
제가 헤르미온느 사진을 보여줬는데
사실 그 머리가 더 가깝긴 하거든요
헤르미온느의 머리에
근데 기필코 그게 아니라고
해그리드라고 이렇게 말했어요
그래서 제가 알겠다
근데 그게 머리가 풍성하니까
너가 얼굴이 작아야 된다
이러면서 이제 저를 또 계속
가스라이팅?
새하얀 속마음을 숨기고
화이트라이팅을 또 하고
화이트라이팅?
화이트라이팅을 해서
그래서 이제 이 머리를 바로 하게 됐죠
그리고 찬영님이 디테일이 굉장히 있잖아요
작업할 때는 되게 예민하시고
그러니까 해그리드 사진을 굳이 보여주고
헤르미온느는 안 된다고 하셨던 거는
그런 거 같아요 디렉팅이
더 산더미같이
산더미
더 스티나 그 약간 그런 볼륨감?
헤어의 볼륨감?
제가 봤을 때 그냥 예쁜 친구의 사진을 들이밀면서
이렇게 하라고? 라고 하는 그 꼴이 보기 싫었던 거 같긴 한데
아니야?
아니야 저는 이 머리가
지금 얼굴에 제일 잘 어울린다고 생각을 했던
그냥 1차원적인
저는 프로듀싱을 항상 그런 식으로 해요
별 큰 게 없어 그냥
그리고 실제로
잘 어울리고
계속 이런 식으로 가스라이팅해서
맞아요 제 인생이 그래요
그리고 본인이 해가지고 별로 안 좋은 거는 언급을 안 할 거야
좋은 거는 봐봐
내 말을 들으니까 어때? 좋아
계속 이거를 하는 거야
그러면은 아 저 사람 말을 들으면은 잘 돼
저 사람 말을 들으면 잘 돼
이렇게 된단 말이죠
맞아요 맞아요
그래서 완전히 세뇌당해 있어요
폼 롤링 롤링 이걸 맞으면 너 잘 될 거야
그럼 이제 그냥 맞는 거죠
나는 너를 바꿀 수 있어
나는 너를 움직이게 할 수 있어
못한다고?
어때 바뀌었지?
네
그럼 바뀌었네 저 사람 말이 맞네
어 진짜 그날 운동이 도움이 되긴 했어
그게 언제부터 시작된 건 줄 알아요?
두 살 때부터
몇 살 차예요?
세 살
세 살 때부터
맞아요
사실 동생은 오빠나 언니 누나 뭐 이런 사람들이
어떻게 가스라이팅을 하느냐에 따라서
이게 바뀝니다
인생이 진짜 바뀌어요
그래서 합숙하시면서 순례길도 하시고
봉사활동 해외도 하시고 여러 가지 하셨는데
그런 거는 앨범 작업할 때 도움이 되겠다 해서 한 거야
그냥 단편적으로 이런 거 해보고 싶다 해서 한 거예요
저희의 이번 앨범은 상황이 먼저예요
우리에게 있었던 일들이 먼저고
여기서 저희는 근 한 3, 4년 동안
저희 가족한테도 되게 많은 일이 있었고
수연이의 상황이 우리 모든 가족한테 큰 영향을 줬죠
근데 이거에 대한 이야기예요 어찌 보면은
그리고 산티아고 간 거 봉사활동 간 거
앨범을 위해서 했다는 말이 틀리지 않은 게
이 앨범 자체가 우리 삶이
달걀이 먼저냐 닭이 먼저냐처럼
어떤 말인지 알 것 같아요
이게 그냥 하나라고 해야 되나
근데 제가 항해를 만들었을 때도 그랬어요
그때도 그냥 제 삶이 통째로 그 앨범으로 들어가서
그게 그거라고 그냥 말할 수 있는
근데 개화도 똑같아요 이번 앨범도
우리의 삶을 압축을 해서 그냥 둔 것 같아요
약간 그런 거지
스팟 스팟마다 그 스팟에 내가 뭘 해야 최선일까를 생각해서
했던 행동들이 쌓인 거를 그대로 떠서 넣으면은
이제 앨범이 되는 건데
이게 7년치가 들어가 있는 거겠나 그러면
거의 근데 3년치가 거의 농축돼서
3년치인데 앞에 그 4년치도 영향을 3년치에 줬을 테니까
결국은 7년이 들어갔다고 볼 수가 있겠네
이번 앨범 같은 경우는 컨셉 같은 게 뭐예요?
저희가 항해 앨범을 내고 1년 만에 앨범 이름을 지었어요
개화라고
우리가 언제 이 앨범을 낼지는 모르겠지만
나는 일단 항해라는 앨범을 내면서 어딘가를 떠났으면
정착할 곳이 분명히 있을 텐데
그 정착할 때면은 막연히 우리가 아마 되게 멋있을 때일 것 같다
그걸 우리가 정착이라고 표현하고 개화라고 할 수 있을 것 같다
그리고 그게 언제가 될지는 몰랐죠 계속
그러다가 자연스럽게 우리가 회사도 떠나서 정착을 했어요
그리고 수연이도
뭔가 이렇게 방황하다가 정착을 했어요
상황들이 다 맞물리면서 지금이다
지금 우리가 꽃을 피우고 있구나
그게 이제 개화입니다
개화라는 게 결국은 그동안 있던 게 에너지가 응축돼서 폭발하듯이 딱 나타나는 건데
일종의 중간 엔딩으로도 볼 수 있겠네요
사실은 식물은 굉장히 중요한 파트잖아요
꽃을 피운다는 거는 나로서의 개체는 여기서 죽어도 좋아
맞아요
딱 만개해서 모든 게 딱 보여주고 했으면
길게 본다면 다음 꽃이 있겠지만
인간 정산 엔딩이라고 볼 수 있잖아요
항상 근데 저는 앨범을 낼 때 이 앨범이 마지막 앨범일 수도 있겠다는 생각을 하면서 내거든요
그럼 매화 개화네 사실은
제 입장에선 좀 그렇죠
근데 악뮤는 또 우리가 함께니까
악뮤가 그 정규앨범이 플레이 사춘기 항해에요
그러니까 나이의 흐름에 좀 같이 가고 있어요
그것까지 좀 겸해서 생각을 했을 때
제가 이제 31살이고 28살이거든요
근데 이제 사회적으로 봤을 때도
아 이렇게 가는 거구나 인생이
그거를 약간 좀 감을 잡고
저한테 좀 더 대입을 하자면 꽤 활동을 했으니까
아 음악 산업이 이렇게 가는 거구나
그리고 작품을 만들 때 이런 것들을 해야 되는 거구나
라는 걸 좀 알고 할 수 있는 때가 됐다
알겠습니다 어떤 느낌인지 알 것 같아요
그러면 이제 타이틀곡 기쁨 슬픔 아름다운 마음이에요
제목은 어떤 뜻으로
맨날 내 말 했으니까 내가 한번
그래요 네
근데 사실 업무는 아니에요
웃어주기랑
제 업무는 사실 아니라
당황스럽긴 한데
사고 안치기인데 애니메이션 추천하기랑
근데 오늘은 특별히 네 번째 곡 설명도
원래는 제목이
기쁨 뒤에 슬픔이 오는 건 아름다운 마음이야
를 통으로 쓰려고 했다가
너무 감당할 수 없이 길어지는 거 같아서
기쁨 슬픔 아름다운 마음이라고 바뀌게 됐는데
본인의 의견이에요 가스레이팅 당했어
어 가스레이팅 당해서
근데 옛날부터 그랬어요 데뷔 전 때부터
아니야 아니야 세 살 때부터 두 살 때부터
두 살이면 나 아직 배 있는데 그때도
그때부터
수윤이가 이 언어의 재능이 있어요
같은 말을 해도 되게 더 솔깃하게 말을 하는
꽂히게
네 꽂히게 대중 친화적으로 내가 말하면 차분해져요
근데 수윤이가 말하면 아 귀여워 이렇게 돼요
그러니까 인터뷰를 할 때 보통 제가 맨 처음에
맨 첫 인터뷰만 하고
2,3,4,5,6을 다 수윤이가 해요
근데 그거를 내가 생각했을 땐 이거다
근데 그게 제 생각이에요
근데 이제 가져간 거야
거기서 열등감이 있구나
열등감?
사실 내가 먼저인데
인정해
아니 내가 생각한 건데 저 사람이 생각한 걸로 생각하네?
열받네?
근데 사람이 꼭
오늘부터 한번 해?
퇴내를 하고 가스레이팅을 하면
그 정도는 감수해야 되는 거 아니에요?
왜냐면은 아 이런 것 같아 라는 게 저에게 입혀지는 거잖아요
그러면 이거는 오빠가 이야기를 해줘서 알게 된 나의 무엇
근데 이게 깜짝 놀라는 게
제가 말을 하면은 수윤이가 이거구나
그래 뭐
좀 다르고 다르거든요
셔츠 보면서 어 비타민을 먹으면 몸에 좋대요
라는 그런 정보를 습득하잖아요
그런 거랑 똑같은 거예요
저도 오빠에게서 어떤 정보를 습득하는 거예요
그리고 어딘가에서 얘기할 때 여러분 비타민이 몸에 좋아요
그거 아시죠?
이렇게 얘기하잖아요
그게 그렇게 기분 나쁠 일은 아니고
근데 비타민이 좋다라는 것은 제가 셔츠에서 봤습니다 라고
출처를 매번 그렇게 이야기할 수 없잖아요
그런 거였어?
똑같다고 생각해요
약간 이런 것도 있는 거야?
4단계 아래 있는 애가 괘씸한데
저는 또 그렇게 생각해요
저는 팀을 생각하거든요
팀을 생각했을 때 내가 말했을 때랑 수윤이가 말했을 때랑
전달력으로 보나 관객 호응으로 보나 이쪽이 더 좋구나라는 거
어릴 때 이미 판단을 했어요
그래서 나는 팀을 위해서 이게 맞다
그럼 곡 설명은 이제 수윤이가
너가 해라
네
기쁨 슬픔 아름다운 마음은요
근데 제가 이걸 두 번밖에 사실 못 들었어요
그래가지고 완벽하지 않을 수가 있는데
점점 어려워지기는 해 곡 설명이
점점 어려워져
옛날에는 그냥 기분 좋은 사랑 노래예요 이랬는데
지금 너무 심오해져가지고
안 되겠다 오빠가 해라 이건 좀
아직 모르지 너
아니야 내가 한번 도전해볼게
수윤이가 어떻게 이별까지 사랑해서 널 사랑하는 거지도
3년 후에 이해를 했거든요
3년 후에 저한테 와서 말을 했어요
오빠 이 노래가 이런 뜻이었어?
네 맞았어요
그 전에는 녹음할 때 조차도 이 노래가 무슨 의미인지 잘 몰랐던 거 같아요
천재네 그러면
무슨 의미인지도 모르고 불렀는데
그 깐깐한 이찬혁이라는 프로듀서의 프로듀싱을 통과를 쉽게 했잖아
그렇다고 볼 수 있죠
대박이네
근데 왜 싫어해요 남친 차라는 걸?
천재
대박이지
천재인 부분이 있어요
몰랐는데도 그거를 막연한 감으로 한 거잖아요
표현을 한 거잖아
대단한 거지
제가 그 어사널사 녹음할 때 이별을 한 번도 안 해봤을 때였어요
그런데도 한 거야?
네 그래서
그거 되게 어려운 건데
맞아요 이별을 한 번도 안 해본 상태로 그걸 녹음을 했어요
잘 맞으시네
잘 맞으면 좋은 거 아니야?
그래서 그게 너무 좋다 이런 결론
아 근데 대단하시네
그래서 이게 좀 시간이 걸리는 거예요
행운이네
아니 작업을 같이 하시더니
행운이야
진짜 좋겠다 부럽다
아니 어떻게
점점 이렇게 밀려나는 느낌인데
아니 그러니까 오세요 안으로 오세요
왜 거기 가있어?
행운은 행운이야
lucky boy
저번에는 그 통천님이 계셔가지고 저희가 좀 팀을 먹고
이렇게 동생이 팀을 먹었었거든요
그랬구나
근데 오늘은 유쾌하지 않네요
근데 저희가 세 명이 있으면 보통은 저랑 다 편을 먹으세요
그래서 보통 이런 구도가 나오기는 하는데
아니 근데 찬영님도 잘해요
찬영님도 충분히 잘하니까
맞아
그렇게 슬퍼하지는 않았으면 좋겠고
오빠도 천재야
충분히 잘하고 있어
잘하고 있어
정말 잘하고 있어
최근에 솔로 앨범 나온 거 상 받았잖아요
충분히 잘해요
맞다
맞다 맞아요
자 곡 설명을 사실은 좀 못 들었어요
아직도 못 들었어
아직도 못 들었는데 사실 또 밖에서 특강하려고 또 오신 계도님이 계시거든요
계도님이랑 만나 뵙고 싶었어요
너무 만나 뵙고 싶었어요
그러면은 요 특강을 들으면서 자연스럽게 그 곡 설명도 하고 요것도 이따가 6시에 곡이 이제 딱 오픈이 돼요
그때 다 같이 한번 또 들어보는 음감의 시간도 있을 겁니다
그러면은 부탁을 하나 드려도 될까요 찬영님한테
계도님 오실 때까지 혼자 여기서 펀치
펀치 라이킹콘 트윗이요
펀치 그거를 좀 시전해 주실 수 있나요
그 원상력도 좀 물어봐야죠
근데 이게 이게 하다가 누군가에게 걸려야지만 멈출 수 있잖아요
맞아요
계도가 등장하면서 계도랑 부딪치면서 멈추는
아 제가 계도님한테 그 디벨롭된 스킬로 해요 아니면은
폼롤러 갖고 오셨어요
아 지금 여기 폼롤러가 없으니까
폼롤러가 없어서 펀치 라이킹콘으로
아 저 칼이 인긴 한데 저건 좀 위험한데
저건 좀 강하니까 펀치 라이트
근데 이게 어쨌든 대상이 있어야 되거든요 그 대상이 없으면
한번 당해보실래요
예 제가 한번 당해볼 수 있을까요
당해볼 수 있을까요
예
누려도 될까요
지금 좀 약간 때리고 싶은 거 아니에요
예 저는 좋아합니다
저 호감
그러면은 계도님 들어오시는 동안 한 대 맞아보도록 하겠습니다
와 이거 오빠의 펀치는 누리기가 쉽지가 않은데
그러니까 솔로 앨범 할 때 상을 또 받으셨거든요
펀치 라이킹콘 투 침착맨
아 안돼 안돼
아니 맞았는데 왜 안 멈춰
펀치 라이킹콘 투 침착맨
멈춰있는 거 맞았잖아
펀치 라이킹콘
아 계속
펀치 라이킹콘 투 침착맨
저기 저기
아 안녕하세요
아니 지금
안녕하세요
카메라 밖에서도 막 계속 때렸어
너무 무서운데
아니 아니에요
괜찮아요
환영하는 파티
오랜만에 좀 무서운데 무서운데
아 계도님 오셨습니다
아 안녕하세요
영광입니다
반갑습니다 반갑습니다
부딪힌게 모잘라 가지고 혼자 지금 소파에도 부딪히고 의자에도 부딪히고 조용히도 부딪히고
나 무서워서 나 지금 쫄았잖아
근데 좀 감정이 섞여있던 것 같은데
아니요 저는 되게
원래 하시던대로?
아니 근데 확실히 해병대라 그런가 피지컬이 좀 있으신 것 같아요
아니 움직임이 달라 이쪽에서 보니까
이게 스피드가?
병건이도 좀 이렇게 물리적으로 좀 강인한 편인데
와 너무 무섭더라고요
저는 거의 자연재해를 본 것 같았어요
천둥을 처음 본 인류 같았어요
대적할 생각을 하는 게 아니고 난 도망가기 바빴어요
너무 무서웠어 깜짝 놀랐어
저는 작품이라고 생각해요
그런 거 음악 작업도 하시지만
행위예술 같은 것도 좀 간간히 한 번 해주셨으면 좋겠어요
그러니까 뭐 이거를
그러니까 그거를 카메라로 담는 거죠
뭐 전시도 한 번 하셨지만
이런 행위예술 위주로만 해서 하는 것도